-President Biden last week
nominated
Judge Ketanji Brown Jackson
to be the first black woman on
the Supreme Court.
She's a DC -- Absolutely.
[ Applause ]
-Absolutely.
She is a DC District Court
judge, a Harvard graduate --
oh, and this is fun --
she also did improve in college.
But more than all those things,
more than all those things,
she's a role model.
Here to talk about that
is one of our writers,
Amber Ruffin, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey.
When I look at
Ketanji Brown-Jackson,
I feel inspired.
[ Gentle music playing ]
I feel motivated,
like I can do anything.
I see her and I think...
♪ Maybe I could be
something so special ♪
♪ If my eyes could
see the future ♪
♪ They'd know that it
looks bright ♪
♪ Maybe I'd be unafraid,
I'd have the ear of a nation ♪
♪ Maybe I could help to
make our wrongs right ♪
Ladies and gentlemen,
Jenny Hagel.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Maybe I could be
something so special ♪
♪ I would try to see
the good in my fellow man ♪
♪ Maybe folks would look to me
to be the inspiration ♪
♪ Women of color would look
at me and know they can ♪
Ladies and gentlemen --
Oh, no. Scollins?
-♪ Maybe I could be -- ♪
-What are you doing?
-I'm inspired,
so I'm singing along.
-No, no. She's inspiring
because she's a woman.
-And 'cause she's black.
-She also did improv, like me.
[ Laughter ]
That inspires me.
-No! Scollins, get out!
-But she -- she was
an improviser!
Seth, tell them.
[ Gentle music continues ]
-I'll allow it.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ Maybe my improv classes
were worth it ♪
-You've got to be kidding me.
-♪ Tell my mom she's not alone
in blowing her two grand ♪
-Oh, gross!
-♪ Maybe improvisers,
as a people ♪
♪ Will finally come together ♪
♪ To take suggestions
and reply "yes, and!" ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ladies and gentlemen, Ally Hord.
-No, Scollins, you ruined it.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes, and by ruining it,
I made it better.
Zip!
-No!
-Zop!
-No!!
-No!
-Boing!
-No, no, no!
-Amber, Jenny -- ugh --
Scollins, Ally, everyone.
We'll be right back
with Amanda Seyfried.
♪♪